vamos a empezar con un espacio vectorial
que vamos a llamarle pues vamos a
llamarle b ya es como nuestra letra
favorita para llamar a los espacios
vectoriales y este sub espacio vectorial
va a ser el espacio vectorial generado
por dos vectores vamos a decir que es el
generado por el vector 1 0 0 1 vamos a
decir este y también por el vector vamos
a decir el 0 1 0 1
y entonces estos dos vectores podemos
notar que forman una base una base de
nuestros de nuestro sub espacio b y en
realidad es que hay que notar que son
linealmente independientes verdad porque
por ejemplo aquí tenemos un elemento
cero tenemos un elemento cero y aquí
tenemos un elemento uno en este en esta
entrada entonces al multiplicar este por
cualquier por cualquier escalar la única
forma de poder hacer que esto sea cero
es multiplicar este vector por cero pero
aquí tenemos un elemento uno y aquí un
cero entonces ya no son compatibles el
hecho de que alguno pueda hacer
múltiples escalar del otro de esta forma
entonces como son linealmente
independientes y generan a todo el
espacio pues entonces son una base de
nuestros de nuestro espacio vectorial ok
ahora en el en el último vídeo y vimos
una forma general de de encontrar cuál
es la matriz de proyección sobre nuestro
su espacio vectorial b y en realidad
tenemos
un vector x x que se encuentra en r 4 ok
y nos interesa calcular quién es la
proyección la proyección sobre nuestro
sub espacio b del vector x donde x puede
ser cualquier vector ok y sabemos que
esto bueno tenemos que construir una
matriz a recuerdan tenemos que construir
la matriz a que es la matriz que tiene
como como columnas a una base de nuestro
espacio vectorial y aquí está esta base
que por eso vimos al inicio del vídeo
entonces esta matriz es la que tiene
este vector como columna y luego este
otro vector como columna que es
justamente la base que tenemos de este
lado entonces la proyección sobre el sub
espacio b de nuestro vector x no es otra
cosa más que una multiplicación de
matrices verdad por aquí teníamos a la
matriz
teníamos algo por aquí adentro y luego
multiplicamos por ha transpuesto al
vector x y realmente lo que teníamos
aquí dentro era la matriz a transpuesta
que multiplicaba
pero había que calcular la inversa ok
entonces lo que tenemos también que
hacer es calcular todas estas
multiplicaciones de matrices que va a
resultar hacer un poco engorroso y medio
complicado
pueden ser expresiones medio difíciles
pero no son imposibles y no pasa nada
así que vamos a hacerlo vamos a tener
que también saber quién es la matriz a
transpuesta y si esta matriz es de de 4
x 2 entonces ésta va a ser de 2 x 4 es
de 2 x 4 y tiene como entradas en las
columnas se convierte en filas y las
filas se convierten en columnas entonces
vamos a tener la matriz
001 vamos a tener aquí ahora el 0 1 0 1
estamos transponiendo esta matriz
la matriz y vamos a continuar con esto
ok vamos a tener la multiplicación vamos
a querer calcular a transpuesta por a ok
para ir calculando esta parte entonces
vamos a calcular esta multiplicación 10
01 01 o que simplemente copiamos lo que
es la matriz a y vamos a hacer esta
multiplicación ahora esta matriz de aquí
es de 2 x 4 y esta de aquí es de 4 por 2
por lo tanto la matriz que me va a
resultar es de 2 por 2 entonces vamos
poniendo eso es una matriz de 2 por 2 y
vamos a ver lo único que hay que hacer
es este renglón a ser producto punto con
este esta columna verdad entonces
simplemente nos queda uno por uno más
cero por cero más cero por cero más uno
por uno entonces eso simplemente nos da
dos muy bien ahora tomamos este renglón
y lo multiplicamos con un producto punto
con con esta columna verdad vamos a
hacerlo entonces tengo uno por cero más
0 por uno más cero por cero más uno por
uno entonces al final sólo nos queda uno
vamos a quitar
queda muy separado
a quitarlo y cerrar mejor muy bien ahora
vámonos con el siguiente paso que ahora
vamos a tomarnos este renglón este
renglón y vamos a multiplicarlo por esta
columna producto punto entonces 0 x 1 es
0 1 por 0 0 0 por 0 0 y simplemente nos
queda uno por uno entonces aquí va 1 y
ahora vamos este mismo renglón pero
ahora otra vez con esta columna entonces
tenemos 0 x 0 más uno por uno ahí
llevamos 10 por 0 y llevamos todavía uno
y uno por uno y eso simplemente nos da
dos muy bien esta matriz de aquí esta
matriz de aquí es a transpuesta por a ok
esta es esta parte de aquí entonces
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es ver
que la la proyección del vector x sobre
nuestro psuv espacio b es esta
multiplicación de matrices donde ya
sabemos quién es a transpuesta x a
hay que calcular la matriz inversa
entonces la matriz inversa es a
transpuesta por a a la menos 1 pues como
es una matriz de 2 x 2 ya sabemos que es
uno entre el determinante y el
determinante es 2 por 24 menos uno por
uno que es uno entonces cuatro menos uno
son tres tenemos que multiplicar por 1
sobre el determinante y ahora estos dos
los invertimos digo es el mismo 2 pero
para que quede claro vamos a dejar los
mismos colores estos dos se invierten y
a estos dos contrarios les cambiamos el
signo entonces aquí va un -1 y acaba un
-1 y ya tenemos esta matriz inversa y
ahora si podemos ir haciendo toda esta
multiplicación de matrices que que puede
resultar un poco el latoso pero vamos a
hacer entonces tenemos que hacer a por a
transpuesta por a la menos 1 por a
transpuesta ok entonces finalmente
sabemos que la proyección sobre nuestro
sub espacio b del vector x
está dado por
vamos a poner la matriz
qué es ésta la que tiene 100 1
101 que multiplica la matriz a
transpuesta a la menos uno que es esta y
este un tercio déjenme ponerlo acá
afuera vamos a poner un tercio que
afuera verdad sólo es un escalar
entonces podemos sacarlo de toda esta
multiplicación y hacemos lo siguiente
multiplicamos por 2 - 1 - 1 2
y luego multiplicamos por esta esta
matriz a transpuesta que es esta que
tenemos que aquí
multiplicamos por la 1 0 0 1 0 1 0 1 y
esto al final hay que multiplicarlo por
nuestro vector x déjenme
el color que teníamos aquí inicialmente
que es morado y aquí multiplicamos por
equis muy bien entonces esto es lo que
hay que calcular vamos a irlo haciendo
poco a poco por ejemplo vamos realizando
primero esta multiplicación esta matriz
de aquí es de 2 x 2 y esta de aquí es de
2 por 4 entonces la matriz que nos
resulta de esta multiplicación será de 2
por 4 muy bien entonces vamos copiando
todo lo que teníamos teníamos un tercio
por nuestra matriz
la matriz voy a dejarlo con el mismo
color es 1 0 0 1 0 1 0 1 y ahora sí
vamos a efectuar esta multiplicación
este renglón vamos a hacer producto
punto con cada una de las columnas y
luego el siguiente renglón muy bien
entonces vamos vamos haciendo esta
matriz dijimos que va a ser de 2 x 4
nos va a ser algo así
o menos va a hacer algo así y entonces
empecemos con el primer renglón
con el primer renglón va a ser este
primer renglón que vamos a multiplicar
por cada una de las columnas entonces va
a ser dos por uno es dos menos uno por
cero es cero entonces nos queda
simplemente dos aquí va a ser dos por
cero es cero más menos uno por uno es
menos uno muy bien tenemos dos por cero
cero más menos uno por cero cero y eso
nos da cero y finalmente es 2 por 12 más
menos uno por uno que es menos uno
entonces tenemos dos menos uno es uno
muy bien vamos ahora con el siguiente
renglón vamos con él con este renglón de
aquí y ahora es menos uno por uno menos
uno más dos por cero que cero entonces
es menos uno menos uno por cero es 0 2
por 1 es 2
nos queda un 2 aquí ok y ahora menos 1
por 0 0 y 2 por 0 es 0 otro 0 de este
lado y menos uno por uno es menos uno
más dos por uno que es 2 nos queda
simplemente 1 al sumarlos muy bien
entonces en efecto si tenemos una matriz
de 2 por 4 y aquí finalmente hay que
multiplicarlo por nuestro vector x muy
bien entonces lo que vamos a hacer ahora
es multiplicar estas dos matrices pero
si nos damos cuenta esta matriz es de 4
por 2 y esta matriz de aquí es de 2 x 4
entonces finalmente de qué tamaño va a
quedar pues va a quedar de 4 por 4
entonces eso va a ser una matriz un
poquito grande pero no pasa de que
hagamos unas cuentas un poquito
complicadas entonces este un tercio lo
voy a dejar aquí fuera
este tercio va a quedarse aquí fuera iba
a ser una matriz de 4x4 más o menos
de este tamaño
y bien vamos haciendo esto simplemente
es multiplicar renglones con columnas ok
renglones con columnas y vamos haciendo
lo paso por paso ok vamos tomándonos
este renglón por cada una de las
columnas y es 1 por 2 que es 2 + 0 por
menos 1 simplemente nos queda 2 más
perdón en el siguiente en la siguiente
entrada queda 1 x menos uno que es menos
uno más cero por dos que cero entonces
nos queda menos uno y de hecho si nos
damos cuenta como la segunda entrada es
cero simplemente vamos a dejar fijo el
primer renglón verdad porque el segundo
no va a contribuir en nada porque
multiplicamos por cero entonces aquí si
se dan cuenta es uno por cero cero por
cero que es cero y uno por uno que es 10
por uno que cero entonces solo nos queda
uno verdad y quedó exactamente el mismo
renglón ahora bien si vamos con el
segundo renglón multiplicando
a cada una de las columnas entonces qué
es lo que nos queda simplemente va a ser
nuevamente como la primera entrada es
cero este no va a jugar en esta
multiplicación y solo vamos a ir
poniendo los de el segundo renglón
entonces aquí nos quedaría menos 1 2 0 y
1 muy bien porque al multiplicar por 0
no cuenta verdad entonces quienes vamos
a multiplicar por 0 todos los del primer
renglón entonces solo nos queda el
segundo renglón y eso tiene sentido
porque esta pequeña matriz de 2 por 2 es
la matriz identidad entonces esto cobra
mucho sentido cuando lo pensamos de esta
forma ahora vamos a pensar en qué ocurre
con los siguientes renglones por ejemplo
aquí tenemos el renglón que es puro 0 no
importa por quién lo multiplique 0 por
lo que sea es 0 0 por lo que sea 0 sigue
siendo 0 entonces aquí tenemos un
renglón de puros ceros y ahora nos queda
1 1
ok vamos a hacerlo y aquí tenemos 1 x 2
es 2 más 1 x menos uno es 1 tenemos en
el siguiente es 1 x menos 1 es menos 1 y
1 por 2 2 que al sumarlos nos da 1
nuevamente aquí tenemos uno por cero más
uno por cero que es cero y finalmente
uno por uno más uno por uno que es 2 ok
y esto lo multiplicamos por nuestro
vector x ahora bien esta matriz ya nos
induce una transformación esto ya es una
transformación y de hecho tiene
muchísimo sentido verdad porque tengo
una proyección sobre un espacio
vectorial es una función que toma
vectores en r4 y me arroja vectores que
también se encuentran en r 4 tiene mucho
sentido la proyección es una
transformación de r 4 en r 4 por lo que
debe tener una matriz asociada y este es
de 4 x 4 de todas formas espero haya
sido útil aunque esto no sea muy
tangible verdad r4 es muy abstracto y
está más allá
ejemplo de programación en tres
dimensiones esto solo fue un ejemplo más
abstracto de cómo hallar una proyección